the next stop will be vanishing on many
interesting topics mixed together so I'm
not going to try to explain to you but
hopefully by the end of the talk at
least you understand the title and all
the terms so but but let's start with
the with the problem which is perhaps
easy to appreciate and has also
applications so imagine that you're
given a graph on n vertices and for
every edge in this graph you are given a
vector V sub e which you can think of as
a matrix capital B which is an N minus 1
cross M matrix so these vectors Levin n
minus 1 dimension that's really the
dimension related to the graph so and
your goal is to find a spanning tree in
this graph which maximizes volume
following volume like quantity so if I
look at for every edge this vector ve in
the spanning tree and look at the volume
of the simplex formed by these vectors I
would like to find a spanning tree with
maximum such volumes in matrix notation
we can write this quantity the volume as
the determinant of V sub T transpose V
sub T where V sub T is the columns of
the matrix V corresponding to the edges
in the tree ok so so this is this is a
simple to state problem it turns out
that it can capture many optimization
problems by playing around with
different vectors you can you can get
pretty much your favorite problem out of
it
and what we would like to do is to find
approximation algorithms for this
problem so this is more of a
mathematical motivation a more machine
learning motivation comes from this data
summarization problem where you are
given a bunch of vectors first one
corresponding to each document so think
of these vectors as feature vectors for
a document and there is a sense of
diversity of these vectors so which is
the measure is exactly the same as what
I described in the previous slide now if
you give me a subset of this the set of
documents we can we can measure its
diversity depending upon the volume of
the simplex form by these vectors and
this measure has been used quite quite a
lot in machine learning and there's a
survey by police and tasks are on this
these these kind of objects are also
called determinantal point processes I'm
not going to go too much into that so
but what is the real problem the problem
is that often we are interested in not
only finding a subset any subset but a
subset which satisfy certain additional
properties and these properties
typically correspond to things like
fairness constraints or resource
constraints or budget constraints that
you impose on the subsets of documents
that you are trying to select and
combinatorially we can think of being
specified a subset B of this entire
subset the set of all subsets of 1 to m
and the optimization problem that we
want to look at is maximize the
determinant with respect to sets in
which lie in this combinatorial family
so there is a discrete part which is the
combinatorial family and then there is a
continuous part which are these vectors
which have some geometry associated to
them so so here is an example for you
know for men B&B is a partition metroid'
we are given subsets of the ground set M
P 1 2 P T there all these
joined and also in addition given some
positive numbers b12 Beatty and what we
would like is that the set s that we
pick has the right intersection in this
case s intersected with PJ is BJ for
every part and you can imagine that your
set of images is divided into two parts
male and female and you would like an
equal representation from both males and
females while at the same time trying to
maximize the geometric diversity of
these images okay so and the example
that I talked about in the previous
slide spanning trees correspond to B
being roughly a regular Metroid and in
this case the specification of this
family is given by the graph whereas in
this case the specification of the
family B is given by these sets and
these numbers okay so it's not always
clear how we would specify the family B
in different contexts the specification
could be different so let's just focus
on these two so think of this as the
partition Metroid and think of this as a
regular Metroid and these are the two
object combinatorial objects that we are
going to focus on and we will address
this question about finding efficient
approximate optimization algorithms for
for these classes of Metroid's so there
is a large body of prior work for this
problem so it started with Koch eons
work on on this family B which
corresponds to picking a single
cardinality constraints and so this set
B is now all subsets of the ground
ground set which are size exactly n and
Koch and gave an end to the N
approximation algorithm for this problem
and this was improved by work of this
amaizing brand
finds and moldenhauer and more recently
by niccolò and the approximation is
something like e to the N and in case
you wonder if you can approximate it
better the answer is not quite so maybe
you can improve improve this constant e
to something better than e but the form
of the result will not change
drastically so it's hard to approximate
better than C to the N for
some see which is positive a more recent
and a different line of attack on this
problem
is is this following set of work
starting starting with the work of
Nicola van Singh who gave an algorithm
which estimates the value of this
optimization problem okay and in fact
the Nikolov and seen generalized the
result of niccolo for a single part to
multiple parts however their algorithm
could not output a set s just output the
value and these results were then
subsequently generalized to various
other Metroid's and in a more general
setting so I talked about this in a
couple of weeks ago I'm not going to say
too much about this work the issue with
this this set of work is I mean so so
the first thing is that these works
somehow seem to rely on this theory of
real stable polynomials which is
delicate and also not clear when it
holds and when it doesn't all these
relaxations I mean all these algorithms
write down a certain convex programming
relaxation for the problem and the
computability of these convex
programming relaxations is actually
quite non-trivial it's not obvious how
to solve these convex programs and in
fact it turns out to be a kind of a very
nuanced question but most importantly
these are all estimation algorithms they
give us no idea as to what the set s
would look like and this is the problem
that we want to address can we find
approximation algorithms for this
constraint sub determinant maximization
problem which are close to in their
approximation ratio for for so I mean
clearly for for this simple setting of
one part these results are there exist
such results but when we go to more
general Metroid's we cannot find such
results okay so this is our main
contribution so the first result is
about regular Metroid's where we give
a randomized approximation algorithm so
this algorithm works with high
probability and outputs are set s such
that its value is within a 2 to the
minus m factor of the optimal so I'm not
stating the result in full generality
but roughly this is what the result says
so this is the kind of factors that we
were seeing in the previous slide and
the distinction from previous work is
that we can also output a set s so this
is a result for regular Metroid's there
is a similar result for partition
Metroid's
where the quality of approximation is
this formula depends upon the size of
the parts and the number of elements
that you can pick from each part this is
a bit mouthful I think the simplest case
is when each part has a constant size
let's say 100 and in that case this
approximation can be seen to be e to the
order R where R is the rank of this
matrix
so these are our two main results
approximation algorithms for for this
subject constraints of determinants
maximization problem in fairly general
settings and while we do not match the
approximation ratios in all cases as
mentioned in the previous slide in
certainly in various interesting cases
the approximation ratio for results is
also tight
okay so I guess the main the main
technical tool which which we use to
prove this is what is called an anti
concentration inequality well I guess we
had a talk just before on concentration
inequalities anti concentration
inequalities say kind of the opposite
that you have a measure space and you
have some function acting on this
measure space it's supposed to be empty
concentrating if it doesn't clump the
mass in any region of this if it's range
okay so you have some domain and you
have some function which acts on it so
it could in principle map this whole
thing to a single point in its range and
that would be quite bad for us so what
we would like to understand is when do
functions have this property that they
are they are kind of well spread so they
don't concentrate mass at any small
subset of of its range so such theorems
are called anti concentration theorems
their study has been rather recent in
mathematics and it's not at all anywhere
close to the kind of work that we know
and the kind of results we know about
and concentration okay so so before I
state our theorem I need a definition
and the definition is the following so
it's a notion of smoothness of a
function of a univariate function I have
a function from 0 1 2 non-negative hours
and we say that it is smooth if for
every constant in the interval 0 1 the
probability that the value of G is at
least C times the maximum value is at
least 1 minus 2 C well maybe the other
way to think about it is the converse
that the probability that G of X is less
than C times G max is less than 2 C so
almost everywhere in this interval the
function takes value which is close to
the
maximum value okay but by almost
everywhere I mean this mid bit large
probability how good an approximation
you want yeah yeah under the uniform
distribution that's right
yeah so we have a uniform distribution
over 0 1 if okay so for a multivariate
function is set to be smooth if this
condition holds for every restriction of
F along a line okay so if you if you
take so if you take any line in this m
dimensional space and you restrict the
polynomial or the function on to this
line then it has this property okay so
and the theorem says that if you have a
function which is smooth in the sense
then at a random point its value is a
good approximation to the optimal value
so optimum is the maximum of f of X in
this domain 0 1 M so I'm sorry I forgot
to put that yes optimum is the maximum
of f of X in this in this entire range
and what we are saying is that if I
sample a random point then it gives me a
good estimate or reasonably good
estimate of the optimum with high
probability so there are two constants
here I mean two numbers here one is this
approximation ratio and one is this
probability in fact the result is much
more general it applies to it applies to
product of simply C's and also these
numbers can be traded off in a variety
of ways so I just did a very special
case which we which we are gonna use in
the results okay so this is this is our
anti concentration inequality and let me
mention also related result by Carberry
and right which proves something similar
in the gaussian world but you can use
this result to derive a result such as
this where instead of e to the minus 4 m
you get something like m to the minus M
okay so you can use some existing
results from mathematics to to to get
size slightly weaker bound than our
results okay so let me so with this with
this tool let me just tell you now what
the algorithmic approach is so the proof
strategy is actually the following so
remember that this is the problem that
we want to solve and the first step is
to write down a function f of X from the
domain 0 1 to the M so that the maximum
of this function is very close or even
equal to the optimal value that you're
interested in so this is an np-hard
quantity to compute
and so we can we can perhaps think of
encoding this as a polynomial or some
such function where if I look at now the
maximum of this it corresponds to or
it's even equal to the optimal the
important thing that we should keep in
mind is that this function should be
easy to evaluate if I give you a point X
then you should be able to tell me what
the value of this function at this point
X is but it doesn't have to be convex
it could be non convex and in fact our
examples will be non convex and once you
have such a thing the algorithm is
really very simple okay just sample a
point at random and round it and often
the rounding is also quite simple I'll
give you one example
so no solving some complicated convex
program no real stability no nothing
it's it's all this you know
straightforward stuff and to prove to
prove that this this this this works we
have to ensure that this function f that
we use as a proxy for the optimal has a
certain smoothness property which we
defined earlier so let's look at an
example and let's look at a sketch of
the proof of the second theorem and
remember that this theorem was about
partition Metroid's
and let's just look at a simple setting
where there are m parts and each part
has two vectors and from every part you
are supposed to pick exactly one vector
so I give you vectors V 1 W 1 V 2 W 2 v
mwm and I ask you to pick one vector
from each of these pairs VI W I says
that the determinant of this u1 the UM
is maximized it turns out that we can
look at the following following non
convex function of which actually
captures a problem exactly so so think
of T as a number between 0 & 1
a positive number between zero and one
and define a vector function uit which
is just the convex combination of V I
and W I at the point t so you take T
times V I plus 1 minus T times W I and
at a point X 1 to X M so this is these
are now numbers between 0 and 1 you
compute the vector UI corresponding to
what the value here is and look at the
determinant of these these vectors so
this is the function it looks like a
nasty function what you can prove is
that the optimum of this problem is
equal to exactly when well this is
obvious right so then if I if I let X to
be only zero or one value then you know
so in each case you're either selecting
VI or W I so that's exactly the same
problem as before so there is nothing
non-trivial here well this is also not
not not non-trivial this is this just
follows from the fact that these
functions have some underlying multi
linearity and that's very important here
it's a non convex function but it has
some underlying multi linearity which
you can use to to show that if I now
relaxed is 0 1 M to the to the hypercube
where you consider even interior points
then the value doesn't change
so it's a high degree non-convex but
kind of a multi linear function
oh my dear fine rather okay this is this
is this is the polynomial I just told
you the relaxation and the rounding I
guess there are many experts here who
would just probably need a couple of
minutes to figure out but the rounding
just follows from looking at univariate
restrictions of this polynomial and
observing that because of multi
linearity one or the two endpoints of
the the interval would maximize as we
can just do it in polynomial times there
is nothing magical about it
so that the thing that we need to prove
is that this function has this
smoothness property yeah
[Music]
it's not I mean yeah not in this not in
this this in this parameterization now
so I have to show you that the function
f is smooth okay and what that means is
the following that suppose I look at
some univariate restriction of this
function and I get a univariate function
G of T well it will be of this form
absolute value of a T plus B where a and
B are some constants and let's look at
an example where a is equal to 1 and B
is equal to minus 1 by 3 then proving
smoothness is essentially the same as or
is exactly exactly the same as showing
that the measure of those T's where the
value of G T is less than C times the
maximum value is that most to see the
proof just follows from picture so this
function absolute value of a T plus B
looks like a V okay and with the root as
you can check at 1 by 3 so this function
vanishes at 1 by 3 and it's linear and
and this is this maximum value which
happens here and this is the line
corresponding to C times the maximum
value and now you can just I mean it's
just a simple high school calculation to
look at what is the measure of this set
where the value is less than C times G
max and that turns out to be in this
case 2 times because there are two sides
times 2/3 of see where these two thirds
you get because of the setting of a and
B and no matter what a and B was this
number can be at most 1 and so the total
mass that you get here is at most 2 C so
that's that's again this this this uses
multi linearity yeah
possession of a symptom is no but but in
what right so this is a strange kind of
a thing right yeah so I mean there are
ways to encode the problem as a
determinant but then we don't
necessarily then we lose all these nice
properties like multi of you know multi
linearity and and smoothness and so on
yeah perhaps if I had more time I would
have shown you how this this thing
differs from the Niccolo singh result
which also uses determinants and and
some kind of relaxations based on that
but then you get convex relaxations but
then they don't it's not clear how to
round them okay so this is this is
essentially the whole proof assuming the
anti concentration inequality I guess I
want to say something about the anti
concentration so I'm going to just tell
you what happens in the regular Metroid
kid what the function is the function is
actually interesting it's it's it's the
following so remember that in the
regular Metroid case what we would need
is these vectors not only these vectors
which are given to us but a
representation of this this Metroid and
so we look at this function okay so it's
the absolute value of determinant of V
xB transpose where X is a diagonal
matrix a corresponding to the variables
x1 to XM so notice that this is a again
highly non symmetric function and a
pretty nasty convex and non convex
function this is there is no hidden
convexity in any of these arguments now
here you can prove that the optimum is
not exactly equal to the maximum but
within some two to the rFactor
multiplicative to the
factor of the optimum so in particular
if the optimum is zero then this is zero
and that's that's that's that's you know
the relaxation at least captures the
zero versus nonzero property and also
gives a reasonable approximation and
then you can follow similar steps I mean
the rounding is a bit more complicated
because you get something more than a
tree in this case and then you have to
remove some elements and prove that you
don't lose in the approximation okay so
let me now in the last five minutes give
you some intuition about the anti
concentration theorem so even if you're
not interested in the applications I
guess this is something which seems
quite general and may be useful in other
other places so this is what we would
like to prove that we are given this
smooth function the probability that the
function takes value at least C to the
minus M times the optimum value is at
least 1 over m so let's say X star is an
optimal solution so X star is the point
where f of X star is optimum and now
let's define this following event a I
where all I have done is fixed the last
from I plus 1 onwards the value which
correspond to the optimal solution the
first I minus 1 are arbitrary values in
0 1 and the I yet on this side is X I
and on here I have replaced it by X I
star okay and I would like to understand
for what choices of X 1 to X I or what
is the measure of those X 1 to X i where
this holds that the function does not
decrease so much and the smoothness
property implies and this is perhaps
requires a couple of minutes to check
but the smoothness property required
gives us that the probability of this
event happening is at least 1/2 and so
what we can try to do is try to chain
this argument so we can look at the
intersection of all these events so if
it is true that a1 happens and a2
happens and a3 happens and a.m. happens
then
because then we know that we can we can
we can derive such a bound and hence the
probability of this event is at least
the probability of this event because
this event implies that if you have this
inequality for all Y then you can just
chain them out at the end because you
have fixed everything you get opt and in
the beginning you just get f of X so you
get this yeah so this is sufficient to
establish a lower bound on this I mean
the issue is that they are not
independent but you can try to do the
following kind of a conditional argument
you can use Bayes rule to write this
intersection as a product of these
probabilities where you have condition
one at a time and the smoothness can
again be seen to imply that the
probability of AI happening conditioned
on all the previous events is at least
half it's just it's a strong property
okay so there are some kind of high
level similarities to real stability
except that we don't really use it
anywhere because it's not true in our
case ok so so this I mean this simple
argument implies that because you know
each of these events happen with
probability at least half that you can
get the probability that the function
takes value at least 4 to the minus 7
times York is at least 2 to the minus M
and now the question is whether we can
improve this 2 to the minus M to
something like 1 over m
well you can play around and you can
recover this bound of em to the - I'm
from this but if you want a constant
probability here but that's this
argument is not going to work beyond
this that's efficient for us yes okay so
so let me just show you what the picture
I mean this now this part is kind of
quite complicated it's technical I will
not be able to explain the whole thing
but let me just show you a picture and
the key to - to this proof is defining
these random variables y:i which are
ratios of the function at X I wherever I
flip the bit X I from optimal to random
okay and so what it does what we do in
our proof is to look at this measure
space or look at the space and do a kind
of a partitioning of this space as a
certain hierarchical partitioning into
where where each set s has is indexed by
M numbers each can be up to a log M so
there are 2 to the M such cells and we
prove that the property that this the
baby construct these cells have the
property that for every point in this in
the set we can lower bound the value or
the ratio of f of X by optimal by some
some number ok these numbers are
carefully calculated and this you know
so this is the technical heart of the
proof and this is roughly implied by the
fact that you can view the smoothness of
F as some kind of tail bounds on minus
log of these random variables weii it is
technical so you know Chandra is giving
me like okay enough so I'll skip through
it and then we require some
combinatorial counting argument
to do this okay so let me just conclude
so so so we gave these efficient
approximation algorithms for constrained
sub determinant maximization problems
they're computationally easy don't rely
on real stability we also give a new
anti concentration inequality for simply
sees and a natural question is can be
generalized this from simply sees to
more general convex bodies okay this
will be useful in in improving the
approximation guarantee and finally a
question that I find very interesting it
can be D randomized our result can be
fine so so many of these probability
inequalities have this flavor they say
that with high probability some event
holds and in this case we have a similar
statement that if I pick a random point
then the probability that the value of
the function is close to optimal is
large can we find such a point
deterministically thank you
[Applause]
yes
so it's one on that extremist question
something else